girl you're not just fine you're hey
what's up guys I'm kitty HD here and
when we got these new MacBook Pros with
you know the new touch bar and
Thunderbolt 3 USB type-c all that fun
stuff we also got this which is the new
LG ultra fine 5k 27 inch display when
this first came out we basically came to
two conclusions one that Apple is sadly
pretty much not in the display business
anymore
we as much as we loved the cinema
display and the IMAX display and as much
as we really wanted just like a
standalone 5k Apple display for Mac it's
probably never going to happen but
number two which is the upside is Apple
basically worked with LG to make this
display the one that they sell an Apple
store and this one as good as possible
for this MacBook Pro so naturally now
our question is how good is this how
well does it work with the MacBook Pro
how good is it of an actual display
that's what I'm here to find out I'm
going to unbox it and set it up I've
also already set up a new MacBook Pro
with touch bars so it's the same
unboxing experience as one without the
touch bar so I'll leave a link to that
video if you want to watch it but this
is a 15-inch it's maxed out it's got the
highest end specs and I've dabbling with
the idea of replacing my trashcan Mac
Pro with it so that's why I'm going to
find out so let's go ahead and see
what's in the box
okay so this is the actual display
pretty clean matte black panel 10 foil a
hat oh well that's kind of nice is kind
of nice so it looks like it also comes
with this accessory box I'm guessing
there's a power cable and maybe some
other input paperwork alright this looks
like a VESA mount so if I want to mount
it like on a wall I could do with this
in our cable just one Thunderbolt cable
and one power cable which makes sense
that's pretty much all you'll need for a
Mac so this is the power cable here and
it plugs where you'd expect right here
there's no cable management at all so I
guess he'll just go straight to the wall
and of course we plug in by a
thunderbolt one of them is highlighted
in the back so I'm going to plug it into
that the other one I will plug into the
left uppermost Thunderbolt port in any
MacBook Pro ok I change the brightness
is the question nope just disowned
brightness right here oh but I can
change the brightness ok good ok so
first thing I notice which is actually
kind of an advantage is this monitor is
now charging the MacBook Pro you can see
it's adding battery and all it's doing
is being plugged in to the monitor via
this one cable so you're getting video
output and charging it's just taking it
in from the wall and charging it that's
an advantage that's kind of what you get
when working with Apple
that's on this monitor also has is
speakers so I'm going to try to listen
to them real quick
it's got some decent volume to it the
speakers in here they're built in
obviously it's not going to be that
great but they're about on par I'd say
with the built-in ones and I'm at and
then actually moving over to put some
content on it I'll go ahead and drag
over this video real quick
this is the main advantage of a display
like this is having the ability to watch
fullscreen native 4k or even above 4k
content and for someone like me who's a
Video Editor that's going to mean I can
have a native 4k video editing window
plus some extra pixels around it to
actually use Final Cut Pro so having two
displays or if you're in my case waiting
for a second one to have two of these
displays plugged into one laptop could
get kind of interesting on the back this
monitor you actually get three more
ports now they're not full size USB or
anything but you do get three more
Thunderbolt ports so if you're really
deep in the Thunderbolt accessory game
already
then you can get into Thunderbolt 3
stuff through the back of this monitor
and use the ports on the laptop so
that's at least expanding how many total
ports you have now you have seven total
instead of four so the idea here is this
is just part one like I said I'm
planning on having potentially replacing
the trashcan mac pro with one macbook
pro and two of these 5k displays I've
tried final cut on this video on this
machine already I'm going to edit this
video and Final Cut Pro on this so if
you never see this video then it didn't
work or I gave up but this is exactly
what Apple was kind of touting and
showing off at the MacBook Pro event
which kind of makes me feel like the Mac
Pro is dead which means like if I'm a
Final Cut editor I kind of have to get
on board with this laptop setup and
editing with a laptop is crazy it
doesn't make a lot of sense to make that
your full-time machine but I guess it's
kind of nice I'll be able to just pack
it up and go I'm going to need a lot of
adapters to do that but at least it's
possible so look I'm going to give this
a shot you can consider this part one of
the video series of me trying out the
Mac style MacBook Pro and the external
display hopefully the next one gets here
soon if I end up liking this enough
that's kind of weird to look at myself
so if I end up liking a set up enough I
will be replacing my Mac Pro with it if
I don't end up
I can get enough thing you'll hear all
about what I don't like about it and
what it can do better and what I end up
switching to because the Mac Pro let's
be fair is aging quite a bit for me let
me know what you guys want to see in
part two this has been your intro let me
know what you think thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you guys the next one
peace